[Music]
did you guys hear about what happened on
the i-95 in virginia no no that's your
hometown baby they don't tell me [ __ ]
over there do you do you know the i-95
have you been on [ __ ] i was kidding i
lived there um so you don't know the
idea do you know it that's a very
california thing though isn't it to know
where all the flowers are you don't have
a personal connection with the freeway
is that one of your favorite freeways
it is not i've been to norfolk i don't
know where no fork is i've heard of it
though yeah you're right it looks like
this
well this is richmond
this is written again
oh nice that's what the map looks like
thousands of people had a terrible
experience getting trapped during a
blizzard on interstate 95 stock
so they just got stuck in their cars and
then they're just waiting so much
traffic you can't and there's so much
snow that they couldn't exactly drive
off the road so they're just stuck right
stranded stuck
and then people are trapped there
overnight people have to sleep in their
cars everyone in the cold in the middle
of the cold
pitch black uh i don't think there were
any deaths thank god huh yeah did they
leave their car running because in a
blizzard you got to keep warm yeah it's
going to be cool there's all kinds of
problems right
um so
somebody was uh coming into virginia
from san francisco
right and they didn't realize what the
[ __ ] was going on they get into an uber
right headed for richmond
and you're in an uber and they fell in
love they fell in love with each other
now they're married yeah that's
surcharge
what a movie dude running through the
marriage too um they were stuck in an
uber together they got stuck in an uber
together how do you piss and [ __ ] this
person ends up getting home after nine
hours and paid a 200 uber bill however
uber then tacked on 400 in additional
charges raising the total to 600 for an
uber trip is it because it was high
traffic hours [ __ ] up it was because
it was high traffic hours hey [ __ ] uber
dude that's so wacky so [ __ ] up dude
it's a 5x surge that's right that's the
blizzard you gotta be able to [ __ ]
appeal that right
like
he's trying he's trying but that's why
it's in the news right it's probably
like some
tech malfunction [ __ ] you know it's like
i don't think a human did plane flight
right and due to some
natural disaster you're supposed to fly
from like l.a to san francisco but then
it had to like land in houston and then
now they charge you double flights
because you went all the way over there
yeah you're like what the [ __ ] that's
not what i paid for no that's that's
[ __ ] i don't know what any context
is that's [ __ ] yeah that's rough
right does it have to be 600 you know
what i mean like that's a lot of money
according to uber's website heavy
traffic may cause your trip to take
longer than expected and to compensate
your driver for the additional time your
fare may change afterwards
oh so it's already in there yeah so this
cat's he's disputing the charge he's
like i'm probably gonna get banned from
uber but [ __ ] it it'll be fine yeah i
think that's
now that's in the press it's so it's so
it's so circumstantial though right
that's like i i understand like the fine
print on that on a [ __ ] contract
that's like you know traffic might
happen something might happen blah blah
you gotta compensate everybody's trying
to win the you know the driver doesn't
shouldn't get [ __ ] either right but
that's a [ __ ] blizzard the driver had
his phone on for the whole nine hours
and they were being charged for the trip
instead of ending the trip oh yeah yeah
the driver is [ __ ] up the trip didn't
end though the driver has to deal with
this [ __ ] too oh driver's working too
[ __ ]
[ __ ] maga people
[ __ ] people were the wrong half of
that one i am mad at the driver but i
think like uber uber can do something
about it they're uber rich right [ __ ]
well but then also like there's the part
where your humanity crosses over your
job right like let's say you're a cop
you get off shift at 5 00 p.m
6 p.m you're driving you see some crazy
[ __ ] happen you don't go well i'm off
the clock so i'm not going to be a cop
right now right cop does the cop goes
looks like i'm about to get some tea
no wrong hat wrong hat all right man
hip hop cup
gotta get some ot oh there you go triple
hats right now
because the uber guy i think like if
you're like the minute it's a natural
disaster you'd be like oh [ __ ] man this
is crazier than my job like let me turn
this off
yeah right or maybe he has no idea what
would happen to the fee i think that's
more likely he probably has no idea like
i don't know man because at that point
it's like hey let's just stay alive
let's just stay alive four hour mark and
we're still there i would not turn it
off because i'm trying to like be you
know humanity and it's ideal i'd
probably be like i'm gonna use my phone
for others yeah and i'm assuming that
app burns batteries yeah you know what i
mean like there's a whole different
circuit
yeah they're plugged in bro all uber
drivers are playing but if it's nine
hours if it's nine hours and the car is
off it's gotta burn batteries that's
true that's what happened to a lot of
people they all had to either turn their
cars off or like try to leave them
running to conserve fuel because some
people were low on gas so it was a [ __ ]
situation wait i thought by keeping it
on you keep the batteries running yeah
but the gas will run out
if you're low on gas you're [ __ ] yeah
so that's what people were dealing with
also a lot of people didn't have food or
water in the car i mean who does right
what the [ __ ] has food in there you guys
don't know i got an emergency kit yes
i keep beef jerky and some granola bars
on my car really yeah some water i don't
know we don't really have blizzard
problems here so i don't really keep we
have earthquake problems though
what about power outage or some [ __ ] in
the car we talking no no dude power
outage is like affecting traffic
so i'm saying like street street lights
and all that [ __ ] you could still drive
away
think because the weather element is
like such like a force of nature that
like really can stop everything yeah you
know what i mean in other states yeah in
other states i feel like maybe we're
privileged enough to only have to deal
with shitty traffic all the time we also
don't have roads like that like that
i-95 or whatever there's nothing around
like you get stuck like that in [ __ ]
the five oh [ __ ] tacos we have
earthquakes yeah earthquakes in l.a that
could crack the ground yeah it could
cause a whole huge sinkhole dude the
frequency of like blizzards and snow
like [ __ ] like that is is very scary you
know it's all vegas has no natural
disasters yeah we got no earthquakes no
tornadoes
no no every now and then the [ __ ]
luxor just erupts
it's really a volcano and just light
yeah
the block is the splash band
some geysers this is this for real no uh
no natural it's just god forsaken
[ __ ] heat yeah yeah yeah say that to
the [ __ ] birds that fly over that
like solar panel energy thing that just
disintegrate
that [ __ ] shiny ass [ __ ] area they
feel no pain though they feel no pain
yeah that's just [ __ ] painking ducks
in the middle of the air speaking ducks
they're so crazy there's street vendors
down there just trying to catch them and
just put them on is this on sticks
it's cheap
uh so people are criticizing the
governor saying that he should have
called the national guard but he was
saying that the
guard a lot of national guard people
have day jobs so it's not just easy to
just get them though he's like they
can't get there they're free oh they're
part-timers
they're like sorry they're working at
target right now like what the [ __ ] do
you expect they have to like assemble
dude like it's a whole thing
i'm surprised there were no uh dudes
with lifted trucks coming to the rescue
you know what i mean like i feel like
virginia would have hella lifted in
front of too much they're like [ __ ] you
guys look you guys don't like my truck
nuts
if you don't like me for my truck nuts
they just drove by
i'm surprised there's no there's like
not a lot of guys with these hats where
like with big ass trucks you know
getting ready to save people why can't
they do [ __ ] for the prius is there's
gonna go by roll call
so like how did it get resolved did [ __ ]
did everybody just waited for it to melt
or suit some people were just out there
for 24 hours and uh yeah waiting for
them to dig get dug out there's a funny
video where like the helicopter was
filming it and then they were following
this one guy they just for some reason
zoomed in on this one random guy while
they were giving the report and the guy
was kind of walking around
looking to shake his [ __ ] and then he
goes he opens both doors to his car and
stands between it and then takes his
dick out and he's about to like and they
go
that's epic
epic yeah what else is he looking around
for you [ __ ] i know like he's looking
for a place why are you following one
guy why didn't he look up
you gotta go you gotta go dude that's
exactly what you do though when you're
on the side of the road you're like all
right yeah the first thing you can think
of is where do i [ __ ] everything melts
and there's just a bunch of human feces
and a bunch of puddles
that's how they get out of the blizzard
never forget we're my family was doing a
family road trip where i was like 13
years old my little brother's like eight
and uh we had to pull off the side of
the road he had to pee so bad it was
crazy so he gets out of the car and he
he runs off the side of the road right
and he takes his dick out and we
immediately just see
his [ __ ] head get hit with a stream
of pee
because he was taking his dick out but
he had to go so bad he was already
letting it go
we were [ __ ] dying dude no yeah he
had pee all over his [ __ ] forehead
and [ __ ]
that is so selfish it was great that is
one thing i hate like if you jump out of
the car and you don't feel where the
wind is going
you have that's the first thing because
you'll just immediately pee on yourself
oh yeah yeah yeah we call him p head for
so long he's like he's like
he's a tender age too like eight years
old so we're calling p head nonstop
that's really traumatic until he's 22.
yeah exactly it's a bad nickname to get
at early age
that's the funniest thing though when
you go on like road trips like with your
church or whatever and someone's got to
take a [ __ ]
and then it's like everyone shits but
it's just so funny when they can't hold
it right i had to diarrhea next to the
church one time
because we were all outside doing
outdoor activities and [ __ ] thankfully
it was night time but yeah i took a fat
[ __ ] outside of outside of a church we
were on a road trip and then we had to
uh this guy george had to take a [ __ ]
and then we started dying right and then
they they pulled over because they kept
trying to come just wait we're gonna get
to a gas station you i can't so then
they pulled over they gave him a roll of
toilet paper he [ __ ] ran into the
forest took a [ __ ] and then this guy was
trying to swag his way back like walk
back with the hand in the pocket with a
toilet paper
everyone was dying dude like why the
[ __ ] are you trying to look so cool on
your way back the whole bus was like
just watching his ass walk back like
with his pants with his hand in his
pants holding the toilet paper and like
[ __ ] sway back and forth you know
what i think actually happened he [ __ ]
himself
yeah dude himself and then after that
he's just like he's like
yeah dude
he's like man this van smells like [ __ ]
guys
boy oh no i took one who's gonna fess up
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you